You've just written the same algorithm twice, once for countries and then for
cars. And you probably passionately wish to never again have to do that for any
other class. So, let's see how we can come up with a generic way of computing
averages. The trouble was that the cars and countries had different ways of
measuring whatever it is that they wanted to be measured by. By with the car it
was the fuel efficiency, with the country it was the area. But let's say they
both agreed on what it meant for them to be measured. Let's say, they both
implemented a common interface. I call this interface measurable. Let's look
inside. It just has a single method, getMeasure. We expect each class that
implements this interface to provide an appropriate implementation for
getMeasure. For example, the country class implements getMeasure to return the
area. The car class has the same method, return miles per gallon. Now, we can
implement a single method in the data class that would take an array of
measurable objects and it will compute the average measure. That's for you to
complete. In the tester, we'll call this method, first on an array of
countries, then we call the same method again on an array of cars. That's what
I mean with the reuse, this method only has to be written once and we can call
it with data sets containing objects of different classes. Now go ahead and
complete the implementation of the average method.